hello and welcome to the third lesson in
native language storica linguistics and
language change this time around using
the concepts that you learned in the
last lesson namely cognates which are
inherited words borrowings and chants I
want you to take a look for a minute at
some basic core words from four
languages these languages are Italian
galician-portuguese and Maori these
words are actually fairly representative
of the relationships between these
languages take a moment to consider
which languages share a common ancestry
and how closely these languages must be
related
we have good grounds for considering
that Portuguese and Galician are very
closely related we also have grounds for
saying that Italian Portuguese and
Galician are less closely related but
they're all related to each other as
long as we group Galician and Portuguese
more closely together in this
relationship we can say that Italian
Galician and Portuguese are all related
to each other Maori on the other hand
doesn't seem to be related at all so at
this point we'll set it to the side and
say that it's an unrelated language that
is it may rebe related to other
languages but it is not related to
Italian Galician and Portuguese at least
as far as we can tell from this set of
words but that's not enough at this
point we just have a flat understanding
of the relationships we should extend
this back the same way we do with family
tree now what we'll do is we'll group
Galician and Portuguese together in one
branch of the tree and then an Italian
in a separate branch of the tree so now
we've extended this relationship back
over time the branches that extend
upwards on this diagram show you that in
the past these languages were actually
more closely related to each other in
other words they diverged from common
ancestors in the case of Galician and
Portuguese they actually diverged from a
nearer common ancestor right you see
that note this note here is the common
ancestor of both Galician and Portuguese
now this note here is also related to
Italian there's an even further note
meaning further back in time that is the
common ancestor of Italian Galician and
Portuguese now we have two question
marks here what do these question marks
mean they're just nodes on our diagram
but they represent more than that
there's actually some language spoken in
the past that must be the common
ancestor of both Galician and Portuguese
otherwise they wouldn't be around they
wouldn't share these common cognates so
these common cognates derived from words
in a single language this single
ancestor language now there's an even
more remote common ends
sir from galician-portuguese in Italian
and that's a form of vulgar latin in at
least some small way these two languages
galician-portuguese and vulgar latin are
attested that means we have documents we
can look back at we can look today at
documents that were written in those
languages we have some attestation of
their existence we know what they look
like we can see their vocabulary items
in written words and based on other
evidence we actually have some knowledge
of how those words were pronounced these
were real languages that are documented
what happens when we don't have that
kind of attestation we'll have to get a
little bit more innovative we'll have to
use something known as reconstruction to
posit a hypothetical ancestor language
that's the parent of the modern
languages in our next lesson we'll look
at how exactly we do that and we'll go
about doing two basic reconstructions to
help you get an understanding for the
process of how we would look back in
time how we would reconstruct an
ancestor language I hope you'll join me
as we do that and gain some more
perspective on historical linguistics
you